es ist der nächste kostenschock auf die
gasanlage da kommt jetzt noch was oben
drauf eine bilanzierungs umlage und eine
gasspeicherung sum lage also werden
diesmal für sie ausgerechnet was für
mehrkosten kommen da zum beispiel für
besitzer eines einfamilienhauses auf die
zu schnitt im jahr sind das
652 euro ordentlich was ja und wo bleibt
die entlastung fragt unter anderem auch
mecklenburg vorpommerns
ministerpräsidentin manuela schwesig es
gebe nicht genügend entlastung in dieser
gaskrise ausgerechnet die ausgerechnet
die schwesig sagte bild politik chef jan
schäfer warum ausgerechnet sie ja
manuela schwesig war wie wenige
politiker spitzenpolitiker in
deutschland eigentlich
verbandelt mit russland mit dem kreml
trat ja bis zuletzt noch ein auch für
den bau dieser umstrittenen gas pipeline
nord stream 2 hat in ihrem bundesland
eine russland tag durchgeführt es gibt
kaum ein bundesland das so enge kontakte
nach russland hatte wie manuela schwesig
und das ist jetzt absolut scheinheilig
was sie macht sie hat sich gestern im
interview im zdf hingestellt und hat
mehr entlastung gefordert vollkommen
richtig aber was eigentlich notwendig
gewesen wäre das wäre eine
entschuldigung von manuela schwesig denn
sie hat mit eingebrockt durch ihre
politik dass der gaspreis jetzt so
explodiert ist mit dafür verantwortlich
dass viele bürger jetzt gar nicht mehr
wissen wie sie die nächste gaspreis
rechnung bezahlen sollen und stellt sich
jetzt hin und fordert und verteilt
wieder um das erst und das wichtigste
wäre zu sagen entschuldigung
entschuldigung es tut mir leid dass ihr
wegen mir mehr zahlen müsste das ist ja
eigentlich das gegenteil passiert
gestern in einem interview sie hat sich
eigentlich ist eine art pipeline
expertin der dargestellt und vielerlei
tipps gegeben warum glaubst du findet
dieser rückblick und ja auch die eigene
bewertung der eigenen politik so wenig
stadt und was sagt das eigentlich den
bürgern gehe weiter davon aus auch bei
uns in mecklenburg vorpommern wir sind
eigentlich vor wirklich für den rest
deutschlands
er schwenkt den manuela schwesig da
hingelegt hat der ist schon
bemerkenswert dass gibt es nicht häufig
in der politik dass man eine so große
180 grad wende eigentlich ist es wenn
das gehen würde einen 360° wenn du
einfach die dimension zu beschreiben
geht natürlich nicht aber eine so
dramatische 180 grad werden hinzulegen
von einer totalen putin verstehe er in
einem totalen russen freund hinzu
jemandem der jetzt plötzlich auch
festgestellt hat ach da habe ich einfach
aufs falsche pferd gesetzt und mich ganz
schön in nesseln gesetzt was zu massiven
kosten vieler vieler bürger geführt und
so stellt sie sich jetzt da sie stellt
sich jetzt neuerdings da als diejenige
die mal wieder auf seiten des bürgers
sein will dafür kämpft dass energie
bezahlbar ist und vergisst leider immer
wieder zu erwähnen dass sie eigentlich
mit schuld daran ist dass viele bürger
sich in diesem dilemma jetzt befinden
jetzt kommt also die gasanlage ist wird
gewaltig teuer wir stecken in der tiefen
gaskrise und fangen jetzt eben an dafür
richtig zu zahlen aber schnell den mut
check deutschland wie wütend ist
deutschland aktuell in deutschland ist
durchaus wütend wir sehen es an vielen
umfragen und es gibt die befürchtung
vieler experten dass vor allem im osten
und wir haben es ja auch gesehen beim
auftritt des bundeskanzlers vergangene
woche dass es dort zu viel viel unmut
kommt viel viel protest auch kommt das
ist zum teil ganz normaler bürger
protest das ist sicherlich auch protest
von rechts und linksextremen gruppierung
die da kommen was wir sehen ist und das
hört man von verbraucherschützern das
hört man von bankmitarbeitern dass es
immer mehr menschen gibt in diesem land
die sich einfach ihre stromrechnung oder
auch ihre gasrechnung nicht mehr leisten
können das ist dann schon etwas wo es
wirklich ans eingemachte geht wenn das
tägliche leben eigentlich unbezahlbar
wird und deswegen gibt es ja auch die
besprechungen und die überlegungen und
die debatte über ein drittes
entlastungspaket für die bundesbürger
weil einfach noch viel zu tun ist und
weil viele diese kosten die es jetzt
gibt nicht mehr tragen können das dritte
entlastungspaket nochmal für alle
zuschauen und zuschauer wie schnell
könnte was kommen viele schauen jetzt
genau werden sie uns zuschauern in ihrem
geldbeutel und sagen ja ist ja schön und
gut aber jetzt muss was passieren also
dann siehst du da ein bisschen
entlastung ein bisschen hoffnung es gibt
verschiedene ankündigungen von
verschiedenen ministern einmal der
bundeskanzler der gesagt hat ja es wird
ein drittes entlastungspaket geben
hubertus heil der arbeitsminister hat es
jetzt auch gesagt ohne konkrete punkte
zu machen und finanzminister lindner hat
schon gesagt dass er die sogenannte
kalte progression verändern möchte also
den steuertarif verschieben möchte das
ist per se erst mal keine entlastung
sondern nur eine anpassung an die
inflation aber es ist zu erwarten dass
es noch mal zuschüsse gibt für
geringverdiener hartz4 soll angepasst
werden zum ersten januar soll dann auch
nicht mehr hartz 4 heißen sondern
bürgergeld und die große frage ist was
passiert mit rentnern was passiert auch
mit studenten dort wird es nach allem
was wir jetzt hören auch nochmal
zuschüsse geben wie hoch die ausfallen
und wie genau die ausgestaltet werden
das kann man jetzt noch nicht sagen ein
kriegsschiff jan schäfer hierzu der wut
im land und zudem war es unsere
politiker im moment dazu beisteuern zum
beispiel spar tipps wo kann man noch
energie wo kann man auch strom sparen wo
kann man noch gas sparen winfried
kretschmann baden württembergs
ministerpräsident der grünen der hat ja
das spitzen beispiel geliefert mit
seinem waschlappen deutschland
diskutiert über den waschlappen von
winfried kretschmann und schuld ist das
zitat von ihm er sagt nämlich duschen
das muss doch nicht immer seien in der
südwest presse hat er das gesagt man
muss doch nicht dauernd duschen auch der
waschlappen ist eben eine brauchbare
erfindung herzlichen dank für diesen
tipp mag vielleicht manch einer von
ihnen jetzt liebe zwischen zuschauer
denken nein aber ohne quatsch wie finden
sie diesen vorschlag singt sie dankbar
dass politiker und tipps geben wie wir
energie sparen sein oder schütteln sie
dann noch den kopf haben sie gefragt
ich kann es mir überhaupt nicht
vorstellen also das ist so ein
schwachsinn alleine meinen job wenn sie
gucken jetzt schon dreckig dort klebt
die hubertshofener die ganze haut vom
leib ich verkaufe bratwurst und so
spitze hier und ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass ich mir das ding hier
noch mehr waschen und so weiter und
stieg die komplette körper geht gar
nicht das ist nach wahl für mich
auschwitz sind witz ist komplett doch
schon sowieso in cannes nicht mehr
duschen weil ich krank bin und da kommt
dann einmal in der woche eine ansonsten
ist der waschlappen da aber das für alle
entschuldigung wie soll das aussehen
dann schickt mich und macht hier und
mach hier und da und das funktioniert
einfach nicht schnell
ja das ist ja nicht mit kleinen kindern
zu tun hat also es muss jeder selber
wissen ob er durch stunde dich nur für
für sein geld einsetzen muss auch jeder
selber
ja und nochmals wasser außen durch ich
mich also deutlich darüber dadurch steht
zu hause mein badezimmer ihre kleines
waschbecken und dann schrieb ich ihren
ganzen tag rum net können sie vergessen
nur weil die regierung jetzt sagt
verzichtet nicht auf meine gene also
sorry
müllwerker aber mit dem waschlappen
brauche ich gar nicht anfangen mich zu
duschen wir haben die gene vor regelung
arbeit und da müssen wir durch nach
jedem arbeitstag für kinder waren mit
waschlappen einschüssen und ein bisschen
mit dem waschlappen ist ja auch nicht
schön
[Gelächter]
klopp
[Musik]
als ergebnis davon weg mit dem
kretschmann waschlappen bitte keine
neuen politiker in energiespar tipps
bitte mehr frank ochse der hat nämlich
richtige spartipps hier in seinem sparer
da schauen sie
ja hier wird jetzt wieder gespart nach
dem wochenende ist natürlich das eisfach
leer der kühlschrank sowieso und da muss
wieder eingekauft werden aber wir wollen
doch gar nicht so viel geld ausgeben und
deswegen kommen hier wirklich die besten
rabatte des tages wir haben also
sämtliche supermarkt angebote auswerten
lassen und nur die größten rabatte
schaffen es hier auf diese wohl dann
fangen wir an was hat aldi nord im
angebot rama cremefine zum kochen für 69
cent und wir wollen mal schauen wie viel
günstiger ist das produkt geworden - 47
prozent im vergleich zur vorwoche also
hier wird richtig kräftig gespart wir
schauen mal was aldi süd dazu bieten hat
39 cent der alm gurt und auch jeder bild
preis check - 50 prozent also ist ja
fast geschenkt tatsächlich edk kommt mit
dem mövenpick eis brombeere ist nicht so
meine sorte aber es gibt auch andere und
zwar für 177 der bottich und auch jeder
check -49 gespart da kann man natürlich
das einfach mal ganz schnell wieder
auffüllen wir wünschen zu kaufland
granini er fruchtsaft ein euro ist ein
schnäppchen und hier der beweis
tatsächlich - 44 dieser rabatt gilt auch
für heute wir machen weiter mit dr
oetker bei lidl das müsli für 199 und
der schnelle bild preis check sagt uns -
47 prozent also auch wirklich grandios
und wir wollen natürlich auch bei müller
joghurt sparen für 33 cent und wir
schauen mal wie viel sie heute sparen
sogar 58 prozent das ist ja wahnsinn es
rabatte heute wieder zum wochenstart
kelly liefert hohes c für 99 cent und
auch hier der check - 44 also hier ist
es wirklich günstig bei diesen marken
artikeln und zum schluss haben wir noch
paar rusty bei rewe für einen euro und
auch hier der preis check - 44 prozent
so kann es gerne weitergehen und ich
melde mich die woche dann nochmal also
ich wünsche ihnen einen schönen spaß am
montag
[Musik]